you think writing and Publishing a
research paper
however is not an easy job it needs time
appropriate training and Mentor guidance
that is why we have designed the omics
logic research fellowship program to
help young researchers as well as
students from diverse range of
backgrounds to take advantage of the
bioinismatic resources for analysis of
complex life science data the fellowship
program will offer a combination of
online resources and Mentor guidance to
prepare you and help you complete a
bioinformatics project more details
about the program such as program
specialization track student project
outcomes registration cost Etc will be
discussed during the webinar
we are also joined by one of our former
research fellow prithvi Baja to share
her journey from being a beginner in
bioinformatics to publishing a research
paper in peer review journals
so before we begin let me also take a
brief moment to introduce you to the
team behind the program we are a
us-based bioinformatics company who is
working with multiple academic and
Commercial collaborators to develop easy
to use analytical tools and our mission
is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
as a part of the program students will
have access to the omix logic training
that has been completed by over 24 000
participants from 187 countries in over
300 workshops and due to this fast
growth our team is working with local
and Regional coordinators that are
helping refine our local program
Logistics and adapting them to the needs
of students and researchers around the
world and this training has been
completed by participants in six
different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omix data
analysis
students will also have access to omic
strategic resources but how does it help
Advance bioinformatics teaching omit's
logic is important for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
it takes a combination of training
modules data analysis tools curated
project data sets and interactive
sessions with mentors to give the
student a clear path up the Bloom's
taxonomy pyramid and no matter what the
user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is who makes logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets and introduction to basic coding
languages like R and python or even
beginning a data analysis project
this also had this also comes with an
access to the omic storage courses which
includes courses on Bank managed
Precision medicine
multi-omics that includes genomics
transatomics metagenomics and
epigenomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using R and python as
well as cheminformatics
and example projects or different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research work users will be
given directions to access the key by
info platform for bioinformatic
processing and Analysis of data the
platform includes demo pipelines as well
as data management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run the bioinformatic
pipelines and different stages of
analysis are performed in different
sections on this multi-omics platform
to view the various courses example
projects student projects you need to
first sign up on the omis logic learn
portal before that let me walk you
through a brief demo on what a completed
profile on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you you need to
update on your account that is a
completed profile will have a profile
image full name with appropriate
capitalization link to your social media
handles a brief bio about yourself that
will consist of your educational
background and research interests the
mentors can view your progress under the
activity Tab and the courses you are
currently completing will appear under
the core system finally after the
completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificates tab
so now you might be wondering what comes
after completing the courses and example
projects as a part of your research
fellowship program the answer is
possibilities are endless for instance
you could go on to perform a research
project like gazra bhargava a
bioinformatics graduate from Amity
University Rajasthan India who completed
a research project in the field of
oncology she uploaded a project on the
loan portal where an International
Community of students peers and
bioinformatics experts can watch her
presentation recordings read through her
research project like share and comment
their feedback under the comment section
another interesting student project
outcome can be seen in case of de la
retaking a molecular biology and
genetics graduate from University of
turkey who completed a project in the
field of astrobiology
which she went on to present at the
psyomix club session a session where an
International Learning Community of
bioinformatic enthusiasts come together
to share their work debate on important
topics and share their queries to stay
up to date with latest advancements in
the field in addition she also went on
to publish her project as a preprint on
bioarchive that she can share with her
peers mentors and potential employers
for future connections further you also
have the opportunity to participate in
poster competitions as a part of formix
research Symposium like Dr umaya Who
worked on machine learning project for
which she won best technical research
project as well as exciting cash prizes
and this Symposium is an international
research Symposium that brings together
experts from diverse range of
backgrounds
the student projects are not just
limited to graduates and doctorates for
instance Andre muradrino Sosa a high
school student at Mexico presented his
Neuroscience project at the regeneron
international science and engineering
fair for which he won the potamkin prize
and the fourth award in biomedical and
Health Sciences category
so now to view the various courses
example projects student projects let us
Begin by signing up on the omics logic
learn portal
for that I am sharing the link in the
chat box please click on the link and
I'll walk you through the process behind
signing up on the portal
so here's the link to sign up on the
portal
all right so for those of you who are
new and wish to uh create an account on
the portal you can go ahead and click on
the options that says create an account
so here you will be asked to enter your
name email ID and password you could
enter this or you also have the option
to log in using any of your social media
accounts such as Google Facebook Apple
account GitHub account or even Twitter
so with that I'll pause for a couple of
minutes so that the participants can
create an account on the portal and I'll
walk you through the process of how you
can view the various courses and example
projects and student projects on the
portal so until then if anyone is having
any queries you can put them in the chat
and once you sign up on the portal
please put a yes in the chat box and if
you already have an account on the
portal you can put it done
and so I'll be monitoring the chat box
is it possible to have the links to the
specific projects that you shared in the
beginning uh yes sure I'll just send it
after the navigating the portal
thank you oh
so I'm waiting for the response from 70
plus participants that are there once
you sign up please put a yes in the chat
box if you already have an account on
the portal please put it done in the
chat box
all right we have
two people who have signed up
absolutely that's great all right so I'm
going to go ahead and log into my
account since I already have an account
I'm just going to go ahead and click on
sign in
all right so once you sign in you're
able to view the various courses and
example projects so let's say your field
of interest is machine learning so you
can simply enter here that asks for
looking for a specific course and simply
enter the
keyword machine learning and that will
show you the various courses and example
projects that makes use of the machine
learning Concepts so you can browse
through this list and view it at your
own pace after the webinar so before
that let me also show you how you can
update your account on the portal that I
was talking about previously for that
click on the tab that says welcome back
with your email ID so once you click on
this you also have the option that you
see here profile here you can enter your
educational background research interest
your name and you can link your social
media handles here
and in my case I've linked my LinkedIn
account and my orc ID so now coming to
the how you can navigate through the
portal so under the activity tab the
community manager and the mentor of the
program will be able to attract your
learning progress under the courses tab
it will display the various courses that
you're currently taking
and once you upload a research project
like Ghazal bhargava it will be
displayed under the project staff and if
you are enrolling for the research
fellowship program the program will be
displayed under the program staff
and after completing the courses with
appropriate assignment and quizzes these
certificates will be appearing under the
certificate stack so now you can also go
through this other student projects that
are there
so for that just click on the tab that
says projects and that will display the
various student projects that range from
oncology infectious diseases uh to
machine learning and so on so you're
here also you can just enter your
keyword like machine learning
and that will display the example
projects that are associated with the uh
keyword that you type all right so I'll
share the link to the projects that are
that I was talking about in the chat box
in the meantime now I'd like to pass on
the stage to rutri Raja our former
research fellow a student from navrachna
University Gujarat to share her journey
from being a beginner in bioinformatics
to publishing a research project and
immunogenetics peer review channel so
over to Unity
[Music]
hi everyone and thank you for the um
kind introduction it's been really long
time since I have been here and she is
so good to be back over here so I'll
just share my screen I hope my screen is
releases
yes it is visible could you please zoom
in so that
can you
please click on play button
um the taskbar is coming in between
yeah can you please click on play button
it will uh the screen will zoom out
yeah thank you yeah so hi everyone
um
today I would be thinking about my
journey with my texts how I got enrolled
at the research parallel so first a
brief introduction about myself I when I
joined fine I was an undergraduate
student in my first year and I was doing
integrated biomedical Sciences now I'm
doing my uh Masters for integrated
biomedical Sciences these are the
specialization in neuroscience and my
interest rise in Neuroscience
urogenetics cancer oncology concerned
with neuros and brain tumors so I had
always this an aesthetic idea about how
do I transform my wet lab ideas into a
dry lab
so then I came across fine biotech and I
joined behind biotech as a Google canvas
I do firstly so after joining as a
growth Ambassador I got to know the
experts over there I interacted with
Elia Dr Mohit and the mentors over there
and then I started talking with the
research fellows that were endorsedment
so my duties are generally comparison of
the social interactions interacting with
students and stuff like that so after
joining us Ambassador and working as
like for three months I then got to know
about the research partnership program
that was conducted Underpants about that
so then my mentors encouraged me to you
know join the research fellowship
program and I definitely learned from my
peers the outcome that we were having so
I then firstly developed the topic of
the internet that I wanted to work on
and as soon as I joined the research
fellowship program I was paired with her
mentor and that Mentor was with me from
the start till the end of my project
that was for the three-month curation
program I was always interested in
Neuroscience so I took multiple
sclerosis and for your information I
never knew about informatics and I
didn't even
platform and trust me that's one of the
best platforms for you to get you know
and inculcated with all these knowledge
because not only bioinformatics but also
all of its branches like genomics
epigenomic transcriptomics
everything was given and the coursework
by posters I don't really mean that they
give you the materials for reading
despite and after the materials they
also have interactive videos animated
videos they have the performance you
know a web browser that is the omics
logic code platform in which you can
enter your code and see if your results
are coming to work and they also have
exercises and assignments and tests for
you to take on your own so that you can
assess yourself on the basis of where
you stand and how much knowledge you
have acquired so after doing this
coursework I work as a research fellow
to find it I said I didn't even know how
to find the data center what a data set
actually meant so the mentors over here
you're not in nurture you so nicely like
I was ashamed telling them that I don't
know data set and how to find them but
uh Dr Mohit Elia and Dr her who was my
mentor they all taught me how to find
the data center that's one-to-one
interaction meeting and every Friday I
guess when I was there every Friday
there was a research fellowship meeting
one for weekly so you discuss your
progress and after discussing your
progress they tell you that okay you're
still in this much now these are my
doubts so they help you solve the doubts
my hands on you know they share the
computer screen and on Hands-On
activities
and in the next meeting you saw their
progressed with them and one of the most
interesting thing of the research
scholarship program is they don't
dictate you that this is how you do your
project it is you who decided what part
you want to they only are there to guide
you that okay if you want to do this
this will tell this one if you want to
do this because then they never tell you
that okay we have designed the project
for you unlike other institutes which
tell that okay we have to assign this
project for you and you can go and do it
and just submit it this is all you know
like a growth process or the process of
finding your own way your own hypothesis
so yeah that the intricacy and the
expositiveness of research fellowship
program over here so after you get
enrolled in the research fellowship
program they train you as a student and
uh then you go to the process of uh
publication and Trust in your research
project and everything
so this is my own experience that why I
particularly got interested in find
biotech created fellowship program and
lots of other some other programs that
is because over here you get a hands-on
experience with bioinformatics tools
earlier I had seen other places where
they give you the coursework and then
they teach YouTube tutorials that this
is how it's written but they don't I
love you to perform the exercises by
yourself over here and not only had an
experience of doing and using all the
bioinformatics tools but I also had an
exposure to you know using the tools
which were on their server which is the
pipeline and that was so useful and not
only the usage of pipeline by one click
but you even get to know the code that
were incremented in designing that uh
pipeline is if anyone wants to go in
that case now what happens is in wet lab
if people have experience it takes years
to get one result or even if if you want
to find any Gene of your interest it
takes years but if you have an idea from
a wet lab and if you want to see in
which direction it goes bioinformatics
is one of the best tools to you know
converge your wet lab hypothesis into a
dry lab hypothesis and get this results
over here if an undergraduate wants to
start a research in an early career I
would definitely recommend fine biotech
research fellowship program because it
not only takes you to the process of
research and Hands-On activity but after
you complete your three months
internship I mean a fellowship program
you even take to the process of crafting
your resources for publication and
research students knows have important
stitches for the publication to go
haywired
so it is the interaction from mentors
not only the in-house mentors I got
exposed to but Pine biotech has research
Symposium uh through twice a year or
once a year and then that you get
critical reviews from mentors from all
over the world and some of the leading
universities which tells you where you
stand how much you need to progress and
I think reviews like that you cannot get
on a normal basis like hey I'm emailing
a professor and I want to review on this
no one would ever care to reply to your
email but getting involved in Pine
biotech not only helped me to do such
things but also participating in the
research in positive help you to learn
from different mentors all over the
world how they uh progress how they work
and my work also got reviews which I
know okay now I need to focus on this
direction I need to move on this
direction I never knew how to write a
research search proposal ordered
research paper for this incident but
after completing this research
Fellowship when I started writing on my
first paper the mentors you know really
helped me out about how to bring out the
layout of the paper what points need to
be addressed what point needs to be
included so it's just not only a project
where you just work on a project and
leave it they expect the outcome now the
outcome could be in the terms of posture
or resistance paper
every week when I say you have to
present your progress you just thought
says that a mentor I have done this
whole thing you have to prepare a proper
Point presentation and show them okay I
did this thing think that my result and
these are my difficulties by doing so
they also are aiming to improve your
presentation skills which is very much
needed in this world so this were the
key Logistics or the key points I
learned from the research program at uh
Pine bartek and I really think that it
stands out because I don't see any other
institutes or companies giving such many
advantages in one goal
sure at least a very brief idea about
what my project was I worked on multiple
sclerosis and I wanted to find out the
genes that are involved in the memory
loss multiple sclerotic patient or if
you've seen that are concerned with any
kind of a regulator or unregulated
pathway so first at Pine Market when you
um enroll for the research fellowship
program actually you have General
coursework and findings like that they
ask you to plan your research proposal
or your hypothesis on which you want to
work for and from there they take it
forward it's definitely like a whole
scientific community and they do
everything a step by and levelize it's
nothing haywired
so after completing my uh project uh I
presented my poster with the same
project as the fine biologist research
symposium
so there were mentors from all over the
world and not only this but my own
mentors helped me to design you know
help me get through the poster because
this was my very first poster and I had
no experience sharing a postage of the
four so I presented the poster that
fantastic research and post them and I
was very thankful because I won the best
citizen fans project award so that was
definitely our learning safe for me but
then I regained my confidence and like
no I can really do this so then I
started doing Hands-On bioinformatics on
my own and trust me now there is no
going back earlier I was so much you
know indecisive of you know who works
with the computers I was running away
from coding I didn't like all these
numbers and stuff and now I'm like
there's no way without bioinformatics
so after doing the poster presentation I
started just my first uh you know
research draft so they were not always
obviously ones that had to go through
the processes so I made I mean I wrote
my first research paper and then put it
on the preprint server and after like 9
to 11 months it got accepted and
immunogenetics open access
a journal so it was uh declared a few
months back so this was about the entire
process regarding how do you go through
the research fellowship program and the
outcome and I would definitely suggest
everyone who is over here to try this
season fellowship program because it
seems that just it's just a research but
when you actually go through it you
cannot even count the number of
advantages it came to for you know your
future not only this interacted with
many uh mentors who are there in the
Symposium while I was present my work
and I had good opportunity to you know
enroll in future programs and stuff like
that so yeah this was about my journey
thank you so much Shruti so does
participants have any kind of queries
related to the research fellowship
program if so please put in the chat box
so uh I have one query for you from
Anamika who's our current research
fellow she was not able to join since
she is having exams so her query was
that what are the publication charges
that come associated with publishing a
paper
so yeah the publication charges depends
on the journal so for my case in if you
want to publish in an Open Access
journal the publication charges are
higher but if you want to publish in a
you know subscription the publication
status are lower but again if you go
with the impact factor that also
deviates in its own kind so I would say
there is an Open Access Journal but if
you are starting with um a low
undergraduate Journal would also work
there are certain generals like um
Colombia undergraduate scientific
journal and long term from publishing
journals which published for free in
Open Access so once if it's very basic
and your first change that paper I think
you can go with that and if as and when
you progress I think Open Access Journal
would work it's not that high also but
if you go for as easier and things like
that the decision itself takes one and a
half years so yeah you can take a call
depending upon your requirements I mean
all right thank you so much and another
query that we have is how do you find a
suitable journal to publish your paper
you could explain with your experience
as well
so initially when I wanted to find the
journal I didn't know I was just
applying and submitting to any journals
but then I got this process so when you
go on Google and type down
www.journalfinder.com to get the links
for the primer and see if your and other
kind of tutorial when you open any one
of that you have to paste your
um generator research paper title you
have to pick your app track and the
keyword and then that third portal would
uh you know create the search Pages for
you and based on your requirement to ask
that if you want to go for the
subscription list open based or free
publishing journals and then you can get
a list and accordingly you can submit so
this is how I used to find your response
and also a second method I would suggest
is if you are submitting it to a prepaid
Journal like this you are asked to fill
a survey from an end of the form you
would be you would be asked a question
that do you want to receive near from
this journal publisher so you have to
take a yes in that just you do so after
a month of submitting your paper on the
paper Journal you'll get a thing like
emails on your account saying that hey
this issue is coming up would you like
to submit so I get thousands of emails
like that every day you would get it if
you sign up for that so based on those
recommendations also you can submit your
paper because they are actually inviting
you to submit your papers so these are
the two ways I used to follow
all right and another query that we have
is what do you look for in the mentor
when you're trying to publish your
research paper
so uh if you're given a chance to choose
your Mentor or you can choose based upon
if your areas of specialization align uh
I think fine biotech has been interested
in every field so you can definitely go
with the mentors in which your area of
specialization all right so that he or
she can better understand your
perspective and thinking
for me I did not look for similarities
because I was very new being in this
field and for me learning was the first
option so any Mentor would suffice that
over here you get the breadth of the
mentor so I don't think there's any um
condenses on what do you want to choose
or how do you want to choose your Mentor
you get the best you know kind of
education from all the mentors so that
wasn't a matter of mind for me
thank you so much and another query that
we have is uh so along the way you have
you must have come across a lot of
mistakes while trying to publish a paper
so what kind of tips and tips do you
have for people who want to publish
their paper and they want to get started
working on a bioinformatics project so
any kind of advice you'd like to give
you yeah yeah so I did not mute the
basic formats of the paper that is
abstract introduction
um methodology in this question results
and conclusions I would suggest that
first read one or two papers and draft
your paper accordingly I mean the topic
wise versus abstract and introduction
keep your language to this I mean you
cannot go on writing paragraphs or
stories because scientific papers and
correspond to the point and third is
you're definitely encounter language
problems but make sure you don't please
realize your text and for this try to
meet your results Innovative in the
sense that they haven't been published
before that would increase the strength
your research paper or the amount of
impact your research paper would have on
the financial company yeah these are the
three points that I launched during my
course
all right and one last query is how much
time would it take for you to like
finalize a manuscript and getting it
published
so after doing the hardcore research
writing took me around one and a half
months I used to dedicate every day one
hour for writing and it came back with
correction when I sent it to my mentor
so obviously that process takes it if
you dedicatedly give time every day like
one one and a half month so we want to
submit and the submittal proposal comes
with addition correction it takes around
9 to 11 months if it gets accepted and
then to get published so yeah one year
you can take into consideration for
Rarity and submission
all right and now there is a question
that is how do we know that the mentor
has checked our research paper when we
publish it online
as in what mentor
okay so over here you have a kind of you
know applicable relationship with your
Mentor so once you have published your
paper online and it's your duty to
inform your mentors by email also Skype
that hey I got about
published so I think the equal deserve
so no so it's our duty to tell our
mentors and not our mentors you need to
ask that is your paper concept or not so
I think that was the question
and we have a lot of queries about the
eligibility that is can pharmaceutical
professionals also take up the courses
and complete a research project
definitely any kind of industry students
can take up this project because data
sets are not concerned to only
biological aspects or machine learning
or any stuff for that you have data sets
for all over the you know queries and
features so anyone can take up this
fellowship program
all right thank you and we have one more
query is this program in bioinformatics
Isha is asking
yeah definitely the hardcore or the idea
behind this project is this program is
still not informatics but again
depending upon your interest you can
choose if you want to go for transfer
Plumbing or genomics or you want to work
at the epigenomics level or you want to
only learn hardcore pudding that is
machine learning so to call this you
have to put the basically is
all right thank you so much for me so
does participants have any further
queries if so please put in the chat box
so that is bioarchive a peer review
journal
bio archive is not a journal and it's
not at all up here YouTube Journal it's
just a preprint server like in case your
article gets published in a journal then
it would link the uh people indirectly
to that journal it's not a dollar
Journal it's just a server where you do
uh ready-made preprints of the papers
which are yet to be published in
different Learners so it's not a journal
don't necessarily yeah
all right thank you so much and where
did you do your wet lab experiments
I don't have I've never experiment in my
university only but this project is not
about my web I just had this idea to be
implemented in wet lab but again you
have ethics and stuff like that I
transformed into this Wildlife
experiment
all right and then
um what are the criteria to get into
this fellowship program
so you would be asked to fill a form if
you want to enroll in this program and
the mentors and the administrators would
view your application and you might have
to go through one interview I guess if
needed and if not then you will send the
details for this program and then you
can improve yourself for this project
okay thank you so much we have a lot
more questions uh these will be covered
uh during the rest of the part of the
webinar so now I'd like to pass on the
stage to sonalika for discussing about
what are the various specialization
tracks and the student projects so over
to you
thank you so much Shri gauri I think
that was a very interesting discussion
and uh it's glad to see you here with me
after a very long time
and thank you for joining today's uh
session and sharing experience with the
other participants because many a time
they asked how all of this would work
and will it be beneficial to them and
they have several questions and to to
and today the idea behind arranging this
webinar was more to have an interactive
discussion about this program what the
outcomes could be and who all can be a
part of this program what are the
different specialization tracks that you
can work on in this program and also
answer other questions right so let's
get started but before I start
discussing about the specialization
tracks I really want to know the
background of the participants who have
joined us today so what is your
background are you all uh students
graduate students or post-graduate
students or are you researchers please
let me know in the chat box and if
you're a student then you're from which
stream is it biotechnology
bioinformatics biochemistry microbiology
or also we have seen interest by medical
students are you a medical student I see
some responses in the chat let's see
okay we have people from computer
science background as well that is nice
PhD in mental health that's interesting
post graduate and bioinformatics so we
have people from different fields today
who have joined the session it's good to
see we have a student in BSE
Neuroscience as well same as request
postgraduate and biochemistry
all right this is good to know about all
of you uh and you all come from
different fields and my second question
to you would be what is your research
and trust and have you do you have a
specific research in trust because of
which you have joined today's webinar
you want to work on a project
your research interests could be a
specialization track maybe that is what
you can tell me in the chat box uh you
want to work with you the neurosciences
in the neurosciences field or you want
to work with infectious diseases or in
the field of oncology
genomics yeah you can also tell me about
different data types that you would like
to work with genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics or epigenomics
all right and many of you who are
students here from Bachelors uh
background VSC students or btech
students and sometimes also it happens
with Master students that they are not
sure uh in which research field they
would like to uh carry out their
research project or simply their
dissertation to submit in their college
that happens and it and it is normal it
is common that it happens and uh this
today this session is to tell you about
the different fields that you can
explore and work on a research project
and if you're a student who does not
have a research interest at all it's all
right we are here to help you out figure
out one and then work uh with that
particular research topic and Excel as
root created all right so without Much
Ado let's now uh discuss about some of
the resources that you can leverage to
either figure out a research interest or
if you have a research interest already
then how can you leverage these
resources to learn about a specific type
of data analysis that you are interested
to learn about and work on your research
project so I will take this step by step
first of all I want you all to have this
link handy that is the link to the
ormystologic learn portal and on this
portal I'll quickly show you some of the
resources that you can leverage and who
will leverage as a part of this research
fellowship program
so uh the research fellowship program
could either be of three months or six
months and in the beginning of this
program we take you through a training
process because obviously if you want to
work with a specific type of data be it
transcriptomic or metagenomic or genomic
or epigenomic it's important for you to
learn about the to get the concepts
clear the concepts cleared about the
specific field maybe and also to learn
about Venus algorithms I'll say or tools
that could be used to analyze that
specific type of data all right and this
training period is from a month to two
months depending on the duration for
which you enroll now this is the courses
tab on the portal where you have all of
these courses listed out I won't be
going in too much depth of the courses
right now but I'll just give you an
overview of what do we have here that
you can learn from so we have mentioned
about different types of omics data that
is one thing I'll just open up one
specific coursework and show you the
different components that we have put
together in each of these courses so we
have three different components that we
have put together the first component is
where we have explained the concepts
related to that specific field so we
have transptonics one coursework where
we are trying to explain what is
transcriptomics first of all what are
the different types of sequencing
techniques how do you get this data and
then how do you process this data and
before processing this data how do you
extract the data from Maybe the public
repositories or if you're a researcher
who is generating this data in your lab
it could be a case that you're a
biotechnologist and you are generating
this data in your lab but you want to
learn how to analyze this data all right
so we begin from the very basic level
different sequencing types then what
type of data format you need to have and
then how you run the pipeline now when
you run the pipeline what are the
biggest algorithms involved in running
these pipelines and I've been talking
about pipelines and algorithms I'll just
show you briefly what this pipeline is
all about what these algorithms are all
about and when you run an algorithm you
need to specify some parameters what are
these and what basis you have to specify
them all of this is mentioned in these
lessons this will help you and guide you
run a pipeline and get the the
required results now when you have your
results in hand it's very important for
you to understand how do you interpret
biological insights from your results so
again all of it is mentioned here in the
coursework now these are simple learn
lessons that will guide you through the
conceptual part and will also give you
some guidelines on how do you run the
pipeline and then how do you interpret
your results
now there are people who want to learn R
coding or maybe use our coding or use
Python good rocks to work with such type
of data and analyze their results so
then we have some specific lessons
transcriptomics and R or transcriptomics
in Python that will
help you and that will help you build
this understanding of how you can use
the r code blog or the python code block
to work with your data to analyze data
and interpret the results that you get
so this was about how different types of
course materials can you find here on
the portal now again you can't directly
jump into transcriptomics in r or python
if you know nothing about RN python you
would definitely uh want to have a basic
setup or know something about how to get
started with our our python as a
language so we have some resources for
you here that you can leverage so you
will find courses on RN python as well
where you will learn from basics
how to specifically set up your art
studio and then load data and read DNA
sequences so this is a very basic
coursework which will help you get
started with this language and also
introduce you to various libraries and
packages and then the second coursework
that was coming up will take you from an
intermediate to an advanced level where
you'll also learn about statistical
analysis and the various data
visualization methods so this was a very
brief overview of what courses have been
put together all right now in your
training you are required to complete a
specific set of coursework based on your
interest and once you have completed
this coursework the question arises how
do I apply the knowledge that I gained
from a specific coursework to answer a
research question
so for that we have some example
projects put together so let's say I
have now completed transcriptomics
training and I want to now uh see how I
could run the transcriptomics pipeline
to work with uh data from liver cancer
patients all right so this is there we
have put together some example projects
for uh our research fellows and also for
Learners who would like to learn you can
go through these example projects to
actually learn how research questions
could be answered uh with the specific
type of training that you will complete
through these courseworks and they are
really good case studies which will help
you build some good uh background to get
started with your research so that was
about courses and example projects now
as I mentioned that when you get started
with your with the coursework it's
important that you have a research
interest and many a times when I meet a
research fellows in their orientation
sessions so when uh where a student
joins the research fellowship program we
basically conduct an orientation session
where we want to understand what is the
interest the research fellow wants to
work on and what are they seeking why
are they working on a project actually
is it for their dissertation to submit
in their college as a requirement to
complete their degree or they are doing
this to get a publication to get
accepted into a PhD program or they are
or if they are if they are a working
professional and just working on a
project to upscale their skill set and
in that orientation session I genuinely
meet students from
graduation and post graduation who are
confused that what should be their
research interest what they should begin
begin with and they don't they are
interested in it's not streamlined that
is what I can say so for them what we
have put together is some research
project topics some specialization
tracks and uh some data types that they
could
um go through for these specialization
tracks so it's a matter of fact that
when you complete your training program
after that you review literature and
come up with a research question but if
you are a student and I'm not sure what
you exactly want to work with you can
explore this page that we have put
together for you I'll just share the
link in the chat all right so here we
are working on six different
specialization tracks that I wanted to
discuss today about so I showed you some
resources that you could learn from and
mutually they revolve around genomic
data analysis transcriptomics data
analysis meta genomics data analysis or
epigenomics data analysis and then we
also have courses on data science how to
use machine learning for biomedical data
analysis and then you also saw the RN
python courseworks that would be used as
a tool to analyze these different types
of data so now we know about these
different types of data and we also know
about different types of research
specialization fields or tracks where
these different types of data
could be analyzed and we have put
together some research questions here
under each specific specialization track
the first one is infectious diseases uh
simply it could be you want to work with
covert data you have some questions put
together here under different types of
data analysis that you can pick you can
take your time to read through this page
after this session is over and let us
know what specific question of Pete and
trusts you the most and what you want to
work on all right so back to infectious
diseases infectious diseases are simply
communicable diseases like Ebola or
covet or also we have some case studies
put together on the portal in the
example projects that you can go through
to get an idea and we have the example
projects linked up here as well if you
want to go through them and see how you
can work on these topics you you have
you can go through the next
specialization track that we have is
oncology
so here we have various types of
research questions that you can answer
under different categories of data
analysis that is possible and uh the
list is very huge in number you can go
through each one of these different
topics and pick the one that interests
you the most and here we also have the
multiomics integration possible and also
researchers and research fellows have
been working with us on structural
biology and chem informatics uh
questions too uh under the field of
oncology again we have the example
projects listed out here for you and the
third specialization track that I would
like to mention about is precision
medicine or personalized medicine we are
currently working in this domain with
transptonic data but yes also there is a
possibility that you can work with
clinical data epigenomic data or genomic
data and under this category and then
you have agriculture as another
specialization track and then different
types of data analysis possible under
this specific track
neurosciences is another interesting
specialization track that you can pick
and we have been working extensively on
Alzheimer's disease Parkinson's disease
and also other neurodegenerated
disorders as neurology neurodegenerative
disorders are among the most researched
topics so this could be one of your
research topic that you would like to
work on as well and at the fifth
specialization track is metabolic
disorders that could be answering some
questions related to diabetes Diabetes
Type 3 is um a topic under research now
and we have few researchers and research
fellows working on Diabetes extensively
so if you want to join them and work
with them in a group it is possible and
yes definitely working on the individual
research project is a possibility
and the last specialization track that I
want to mention is space omics now this
is one of uh the most interesting fields
that is evolving and we have some
amazing space omics research projects
that I would like to definitely take you
uh through I'll just show you these
projects that you can go through and see
what is the possibility uh for you to
work on such a project again I'll repeat
the link is with you in the chat box
we'll also share it with you over an
email you can take time to go through
each one of the research questions or
topics that we have mentioned under each
type of analysis under each
specialization track and think of what
you would like to work on
and that was it I did not take up each
one of the questions because it would
have taken more time
all right now the question arises that
we have talked about different types of
data analysis and specialization tracks
but where do you run these pipelines
that I was just mentioning about and
discussed about algorithms and where do
you have all of this data analysis
possible so the answer to that is the T
bioinfo server now this is the T by info
server the Hands-On practical server
that you will be using to run all the
different types of pipelines for
different types of analysis here you
have all these analysis put together and
different sections uh you have the
transcript on data analysis section then
the genomic data analysis metagenomics
is here Data Mining and then you have
some phylogenic analysis possible here
on the server as well I can see a
question in the chat I just stake up in
a minute
or I can answer it now because because
it's related to the specialization track
that we just discussed so Gibson is
asking every resource specialization is
interesting what are the key criteria to
consider when deciding which research
specialization to go for
now criteria could is definitely the
first one is your interest what is your
interest what you want to work on the
second one could be where you in which
field you want to do your Majors uh if
you're a graduate student and you want
to post your Masters it would be in
which field or a PhD a PhD degree then
in which field what are you entrusted to
learn about because it is more important
to streamline your interest with the
learning and if you don't have an
interest let's say if you don't have an
interest though that's a very big thing
but still if you don't have an interest
you can maybe pick up one of the
research questions that is
um that is more under
um I'll say curiosity of the researchers
and they're working on and you think
that you would like to add on to the
research Society by working on that
topic you can pick that but again it's
the interest that you want to work on
and where you see your uh career going
or where you where you see your videos
where you see you pursuing your Majors
into I hope that answers your questions
um
all right so now getting back to the
server where I was just showing you the
different areas of analysis and
different sections on the server so here
you have these drop downs which will
take you to some demo pipelines now
before you join a program you if you
want to see how the server works and how
these different pipelines are arranged
you can create an account on the omics
logic learn portal and that will help
you get an account on the server as well
after 24 hours and then with that
account you can access some of the demo
pipelines and see how these pipelines
basically work I will just show you one
simple pipeline today and uh it would be
a very brief a very brief pipeline just
just to Showcase how interesting it is
and how to how interesting and easy it
is to run a pipeline on the table info
server and how interactive the results
look like so here we have a demo
Pipeline on breast cancer and uh this is
a demo pipeline where the data is
already uploaded at the back end and we
just run the pipeline and see what the
flow of the pipeline looks like and what
the results look like so I'll just give
you a background of what this pipeline
is this is a breast cancer pipeline
where you have 10 patients
um of different types of breast cancers
I'll say the first five patients are ER
positive breast cancer type patients and
the other fiber triple negative breast
cancer patients now I am interested to
look what are other different
differential expressed genes among both
of these groups and also they know about
the Pathways in which these genes are
involved so let's begin with this
pipeline
yes so there are no prerequisites
actually to perform the data analysis
Kishore and it is not important that you
have a software background to run a
specific pipeline we'll be teaching you
everything you need to know about a
pipeline what type of data you upload
how you run the pipeline and how do you
interpret the results in the training
process when you join the research
fellowship program so you need not have
a software background to do so all right
now getting back to the pipeline I start
the pipeline and then to look for the
for the differentiating express genes I
click on the D6 uh two option and then
to look at the pathways involved I will
select enrichment analysis and glca and
simply in my pipeline now when I end my
pipeline as I told you it's a demo
pipeline we already have our results put
together and now I'll quickly open these
results to show you how easy it is to
understand what the results look like
interpret biological insights now we
have a list of results that are put
together here we can download these zip
folders and extract the fines and look
at the differentially expressed genes we
have some very interesting plots and we
also have some very interesting txt
files put together where we can see the
value of each differentially expressed
chain I'll look for each and every Gene
with regards to the samples so this is a
volcano plot that you see now these
plots are interactive you can see which
is the gene that is differentially
expressed what is the log fold change
and these terms that I am using it's not
important that you understand it now we
will we will definitely take you through
the training process where you learn
about it all and this is a heat map
which clear cut shows you what is the
expression level of different types of
genes in different samples and more the
expression level
uh more different is the expression
level highly is the differentially
expressed genes that are mentioned here
in the heat map and then you have some
interactive dashboards where you can uh
interact with these results and also
interpret what the results look like all
right so you can play around you can
increase the full change values and then
look at the differential we expressed
chains
and also if you want to look at the
pathways then you can click on the
enrichment button right here and you
will get these Pathways along with the
gene ratio and you will get to know
about what all other Pathways involved
here
so that was a very brief overview of how
you can run a pipeline and just to
Showcase you how easy it is to run this
Pipeline and then interact with these
results
all right now my last question is what
after research fellowship program so one
possibility is definitely as Roti has
shown has uh shown a publication as well
and told you it is the publication that
you can get if you dedicate good number
of fans to the research fellowship
program and work on this program so here
are some of the Publications that we
have got by research fellows and you can
go through these Publications here is
the link in the chat box and another
outcome could be publication on the
omics logic learn portal as well now
there are many students in researchers
who work on a short-term project maybe
and so what they do is they submit their
project once it's completed on the
portal and then when they extend their
Fellowship they complete their validate
their project and then take it towards
the publication so we have all our
projects here uploaded uh under the
projects tab on the omics logic learn
portal and you can go to the portal and
look at some of these project
Publications to see in which all
different specialization tracks and with
which all different data types are
research fellows have completed their
research projects
so that was all that I wanted to discuss
I think I'm over time so I'll be now
handing over the stage to spudge and
meanwhile Spar shares a screen if there
are any questions please put them in the
chat box so that we can answer
foreign
for like explaining the research topics
Etc very comprehensively I guess there
is a question are these courses paid and
do they have certificates as well so
sonalika could you please answer this
question
yes uh special take the sharing option
back from you yeah yeah sure no problem
so uh when you joined the research
fellowship program the access to the
courses included in it you get the
access to all the courses and all the
example projects as a part of the
research fellowship program that is
point number one and when you complete
each one of these courses in your
training
um part so I mentioned that when you
join the program you have to complete uh
training a coursework I'll say in the
initial days of your research project to
get yourself trained to work on a
research project so when you complete
these courseworks you can certificate
for it so you will get a certificate for
each one of these courses and you will
get a research certificate when you
complete and submit your research
project on the portal all right so where
do you get your certificates this is uh
the profile tab you need to click on
this email address of yours that come
comes in the main menu bar and when you
click on on this you will be redirected
to your profile now we monitor our
research fellows progress and a user's
progress through profiles where we can
see what all they have been working on
recently and for completing each of
these uh courses uh and lessons in these
courses you get some points that will
take you from a beginner level to an
advanced level so this is the tab where
you get all your certificates when you
complete a particular coursework this is
the part where you you can see virtual
courses you have completed as started
off with some of these courses here so
when you complete a specific coursework
you get your certificate so yes you will
get a certificate for completing each of
the courses and the example project
throughout your training duration and
you will also get a research certificate
when you submit your research project I
hope that answers your question
uh Pamela you cannot access all the
lessons in the courses if you are not a
part of the fellowship program you can
access the unstarred lessons which are
introductory lessons to give him a sense
of a specific
topic that coursework refers to all
right so in the coursework you have some
lessons which are unstart you can access
needs to uh just have an idea about the
specific topic and to see if you want to
take up the start lessons on it
thank you Pamela uh
yes thank you uh sonalika
okay uh so hello everyone my name is
sparsh and I'm the marketing manager
here at Pine biotech so I'll quickly
guide you through the registration steps
and the different resources which you'll
have access to if you'll enroll in a
bioinformatics and data science research
fellowship program
so here is the landing page of the
research fellowship program and you can
go through with this particular page
after the session gets over
and if you feel any query so later on
I'll share the email address on which
you can ping and we can discuss it
further like comprehensively now moving
further so this is a research fellowship
program as uh discussed earlier this
particular program is not for only
biosciences students anyone from any
background whether it is a computer
science student or a student from a
Pharma background anyone can join this
particular program and can start
analyzing complex life science data and
become first in bioinformatics now how
so this particular research fellowship
program we have designed in such a way
that we will be uh like we'll be
we'll be teaching you we'll be training
you from Basics then we'll be
transacting you from Basics to
intermediate and then from intermediate
to advanced level and then we'll be
guiding you how you can or how any
participant can develop a research
project after uh gaining appropriate
conceptual as well as practical
knowledge based on their
it is such interest so uh now scrolling
down so these are the three basic steps
or these are the like stages which one
need to go through so the first stage in
a very Layman language at the first
stage is to get yourself trained so uh
like as sonalika showed you the omics
logic loan portal so there are different
data types on which you can work on uh
for example genomics for example
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
then there is a new immersion field
called space omic so uh those who are
having interests in multinomic fields
then there is a field called data
science in our data science in Python
then machine learning then we have
um some specialization tracks like
Precision medicine neurosciences
infectious diseases Etc So based on your
research interest the mentors will guide
you which all courses you need to take
up and you need to go through so that
you gain that appropriate conceptual
knowledge which will help you eventually
in your next stage so that you can come
up with a good research question prepare
a good methodology come up with the data
set one which you need to eventually
work on and finally develop a research
project so the first thing is get ready
through training so topics what we'll be
covering is Introduction to
bioinformatics and basics of data and
Life Sciences so that you get to know
about the insights on the glimpse of
what exactly is bioinformatics different
terminologies uh different Healthcare
applications and how bioinformatics is
being used in translational research Etc
then we'll be guiding you through omics
data types like genomics transcriptomics
or metagenomics then data science and
machine learning for non-engineers and
biologists and then are in Python
Programming and in-depth analytics for
complex omics data so these are the
topics which is there in our omix logic
loan portal and based on your research
interest you can opt one and start
learning and start gaining the Train the
training now for some of the top some of
the points which you need to remember
while you are in your research
fellowship program that is you should
make sure that your research question is
compelling to those already in the field
it should be novel second set specific
parameters to answer the research
question conclusively
find a data set that fits your
objectives and explore them for batch
effects or bias and fourth get feedback
from our expert mentors on your topic
and Analysis proposal so in the first
stage you'll get yourself trained and in
the second stage you will start working
by reviewing literature extensively then
once your research question is fixed on
which you need to work on you'll fix a
data set or which uh like do the
analysis once your data set is finalized
you'll start preparing the methodology
on it or that you need to follow so that
you can come up with the results and in
the end do the statistical or the
biological interpretation of those
results and in the end whatever you have
done you need to prepare a kind of
report or a manuscript so as to submit
now what are the potential outcomes of
This research fellowship program when
you join number one is expert feedback
and overall evaluation of project
quality Innovation analysis execution so
you will be getting feedback not only
from our time biotic mentors but also
from our industry experts now second is
the poster presentation at the research
fellowship meeting or a research
symposium so we organize buy a new omics
research Symposium where our
participants get an opportunity to
present their research project what they
have done till now and also gets
exciting uh prizes cash prizes after the
results are up so the third is path to
collaboration with expert mentors or
faculty at partner universities and the
last but not the least path to a full
publication
as you scroll down you will find three
different tenures
now there are three different tenures on
which one can work on rather I would say
four different tenures one is 45 days
another is 60 days then it's 90 days and
then is 180 days or six months in all
the four tenures the com the resources
are you will have access to the
asynchronous courses that is uh you will
have access to the omics logic loan
portal where you will be covering basic
still Advanced training courses and
lessons then you will have access to the
Hands-On assignments you will have
access to the group sessions you will
have access to the omics logic program
access educational Cloud pipelines
online Venture Support Online technical
support
Etc so these are the resources which one
would have access to when they will
enroll for this particular program now
the resources are same but the outcome
for or outcome is different for all
three or four uh tenures the outcome for
45 days is a literature review and a
project report then for 60 days it's
literature review project report and a
research poster for 90 days it's
literature review project report and a
research paper publication same goes for
180 days also now the question arises
how one can enroll and like the payment
checkout links for the research
fellowship program and how one can
proceed with the payment uh
so here we have provided with all four
payment checkout links and if anyone is
from low income country so if the
scholarship opportunities are available
and you can reach out to us at the given
uh mentioned or email address that is
marketing at the omxlogic.com and we
will be providing you with like the best
possible way like helping you out with
the best possible way so that you can
enroll in this particular program and
start with and get started with the
training and the research part so now uh
moving back to the payment checkout for
example if someone is interested in 45
days you need to Simply click on this
link it will be redirected to the
payment page
so it's taking a little bit tighten yeah
so now what you need to do is you need
to Simply uh you know add uh put some of
your details over here payment
information
Etc and click on the payment of pay or
pay button and you'll be uh like
the uh you will be uh done with the
payment part so by this uh your payment
is done and after one
as your payment is done we'll be
organizing an orientation session of
yours where we'll be navigating you
through the both the platform status or
mixed logic loan portal and the T by
info server as soon Alika showed you now
here are some of the student projects uh
which is being published on our mix
logic loan portal and these projects are
on different domains as you can see some
students have worked on infectious
diseases some on space or make some on
Precision oncology then machine learning
and modeling skin diseases data-driven
drug Discovery Etc so this was a little
brief about the research fellowship
program the resources which one would
have access to the different domains on
which you can work on the different
tenures and the payment process so if
anyone is having any kind of question
related to registration step payment Etc
please feel free to Ping in the chat box
and I'll be there to assist and answer
your question thank you
hi thank you so much so we have one
query from Pamela that is uh she's
interested in the fellowship and she is
a postdoctoral and she needs to start
learning the bioinformatics as well as
possible so which one would you suggest
the best option for her
no so this uh research fellowship
program like it's you can say it's
active throughout the air so anyone
according to their visibility can join
this particular program uh for any 10
years so there's like there's no
deadline for it
and anyone can learn in any domain so if
someone is into bioinformatics so the
research project can be totally oriented
towards bioinformatics and computational
biology and multi-amic thing if someone
is interested in infectious diseases so
it can be totally oriented towards the
infectious diseases as part
Etc yeah I hope this answer your
questions
thank you so much so does participants
have any further queries if so this is
the best time to ask you can either put
them in the chat or we can give you
access to unmute yourself and ask the
query and just as a note for the
participants we will be mailing out the
today's recordings uh to all the
participants all right thank you so much
Pamela so if you want any links to be
reshared once more you can let me know
we will be happy to re-share
I'll just pause for a few more minutes
so that if the participants have any
queries you can put it in the chat
[Music]
all right uh suction Bhatia is asking
for telegram links if ogc or sparsh you
could just share their telegram links to
the group
um sure uh I guess shubham is here and
he can share the appropriate research
fellowship program telegram link here in
the chat box shubham could you please do
this
and we have another query that is does
belonging to a collaborative University
have any books
um yes definitely anjal so uh if a
student from a collaborative University
joins our research fellowship program or
any Mentor guided program so we have a
special scholarship for those students
and uh yes so like in terms of uh like
payments and all you have Perks rest the
guidance and all is similar for all
students anyone from any University
whether it is a collaborative or
non-collaborative one
uh thank you so much parsh and ojasvi
has shared the links to the various
groups that are there so the
participants can take a look at it
and does anyone have any further queries
[Music]
and another query is uh do we have to do
the research project in groups
um no so it's not necessary you can do
it individually uh if you have like if
you're uh your colleagues or your
friends are with you you can do it
collectively in a group also it's
completely on you if you want to do it
individually or in a group
thank you so much and Pamela is asking
another query do you teach based on the
platform you show or do you teach how to
use other tools as well
um so yes Pamela we uh we work we
basically work on two different
platforms one is our learning portal and
another is an analysis portal platform
that is logical and portal and T by info
server but if you specifically opt for
uh like a cheminformatics kind of
specialization tracks so we do teach
other tools which are related to chem
informatics background like uh Orthodox
tools or for qsar modeling Etc so we do
teach other kind of two results which
are used for specific kind of
specialization track
maybe to add to that
um you know we actually offer the
platform as a way to process data on the
cloud
but behind each one of those methods
there's some kind of a commonly known
published method that is typically used
for that type of data they're packaged
on the platform for someone to be able
to use them using a graphical interface
but we also have in the lessons that
were described the actual code on how
you would call and run that method in r
or in Python
thank you so much parsh and uh yes sir
so we have another query when is the
deadline for the payment
um so as like November is fast
approaching so we'll be starting our
next RF patch from November 1. so it
would be great if anyone who is
interested in research fellowship
program so they can proceed with the
payment check out in two to three days
and they can't be enrolled in the
upcoming batch from November one yeah
oops thank you so much do you have any
further queries if so please put them in
the chat box
and we'll be happy to help if you're
facing any kind of technical issues
while signing up
or any kind of queries related to the
research fellowship program you can put
it in the chat
[Music]
or just me
and any book suggestions for
undergraduates before enrolling
um so unknown not particularly because
like our learning portal is uh
sufficient for making you trained or
what uh the conceptual skills what you
require to do or complete a developer
research project so not no specific book
suggestions are there
uh we we do have
um some suggestions I would say if you
go to the portal inside the introduction
to bioinformatics and the bytes and
molecules course which both are free you
don't have to pay for anything to
complete those courses and get a
certificate inside those courses there's
a lot of additional links to
um different articles research articles
Publications books so please take a look
at those two and and once you complete
those and you have any additional
questions I think we would be happy to
recommend
um other resources if you're interested
thank you so much and we'll just be has
shared uh some of the links to the
courses that we have
so far if the participants do not have
any further queries
we are good to end today's webinar and
we also have another webinar uh where we
have invited another research fellow who
has published his research project and
uh it will be on November 4th next week
and we'll be sending out the details of
the webinar in the email as well so
please make sure to join and if you have
any further queries you can reach out to
the email ID that has been provided in
the chat box
so with that thank you everyone for
joining today's webinar and thank you so
much for your patience and have a great
day thank you